tine chat un village isolé dans les
montagnes du sud-est de la chine entre
les champs de thé des bâtiments en
façade triste
les maisons des paysans
aujourd'hui pourtant une ambiance de
fête règne chez shao lui un cultivateur
de thé de 28 ans il vient tout juste
d'épouser tuyen 18 ans et il est fier de
montrer aux amis du village
les photos de la cérémonie regardez ces
photos mais tu es très beau là dessus il
faut les faire plastifiée les mettre
dans un album parce qu'elles sont
magnifiques mais sur les photos
certains détails ne trompent pas le
mariage de tuyen et shao lui n'est pas
tout à fait comme les autres
à vous de vous embrasser pas vraiment
quand il embrasse sa femme on dirait
qu'il embrasse du vent
la fête a été somptueuse une centaine
d'invités choisi par la famille de la
mariée et cette fête s'est déroulée à
3500 km du village au vietnam
car tu viennes vietnam hier
il
ça te fait quoi de voir ces images ma
famille me manque
les femmes qui regardent ces images sont
toutes des vietnamiennes maria des
chinois de tim chat elles ont vécu la
même histoire que tu viennes elles ont
quitté leur pays et surtout elles ont
été achetées par leur mari shao lui a
dépensé pas moins de 5000 euros pour
acquérir tuyen l'équivalent de dix ans
de travail
au village les jeunes filles sont partis
à la ville trouver un mari plus riches
les hommes eux restent livrés à leur
solitude
les chinois les appels branche esseulé
ils sont des millions dans le pays et
ils n'hésitent plus à franchir les
frontières pour se marier
nous allons vous raconter comment shao
lui a rencontré sa femme tuyen un long
périple orchestrée par des trafiquants
peu scrupuleux
une odyssée où le mot amour ne sera pas
prononcée
[Musique]
au chi minh ville capitale économique du
vietnam
un mois plus tôt c'est dans cette
mégalopole de 7 millions d'habitants que
la rencontre entre les deux futurs époux
va avoir lieu depuis cinq ans ho chi
minh ville voit arriver des milliers de
branche est ce les venues de chine pour
un séjour de quelques semaines les
célibataires rencontre les trafiquants
dans des hôtels entièrement dédié à ce
business
nous retrouvons shao lui le cultivateur
chinois cela fait quinze jours qu'il est
ici les trafiquants lui ont confisqué
son passeport il accepte que nous le
film ion à condition que nous soyons
discret l'hôtel est sous haute
surveillance
nous tournons en caméra cachée dans le
hall d'entrée des dizaines de branches
et se les passent leurs journées à
attendre
privé de passeport ils n'ont pas le
droit de sortir ils ont déjà payé les
trafiquants mais ces derniers ne leur
ont encore présenter personne pour shao
lui le moment de la rencontre est
arrivée elle va avoir lieu dans sa
chambre d'hôtel
les trafiquants lui ont donné un manuel
de conversations en vietnamien mais il
préférera sollicité notre interprète
assieds toi
tu es très belle il faut que tu le
traduisent merci je ne sais pas si tu as
un petit ami vietnamien non je suis
chinois est ce que tu veux venir en
chine avec moi
au début ça va être difficile mais tu
vas t'y habituer une fois qu'on aura un
bébé dans deux à trois ans on reviendra
ici voir ta famille elle te plaît oui
elle me plaît mais tu ne la connais pas
note ce n'est pas grave on devine au
rased douleur sympa firmi accra des
salaires
elle me plait ça me suffit comment tu
imagines ta vie en chine une vie
heureuse et c'est quoi le bonheur pour
toi
je ne sais pas j
voici la femme qui a arrangé la
rencontre elle s'appelle madame wang
elle est chinoise et elle est l'une des
responsables de ce réseau de vente de
femmes
il nous a fallu plusieurs mois pour la
convaincre de nous accueillir
si la police vietnamienne l'art est elle
risque 17 ans de prison
madame wang ne veut pas être filmés nous
la suivons en caméra cachée elle nous
parle avec fierté de son activité
je me suis occupé de centaines de
brancher seul et parfois les branchies
solide un village entier font appel à
mort et comment il vous remercie
ils me donnent de l'argent je fais tout
le nécessaire pour qu'ils retournent en
chine avec une femme
le lendemain matin à la gare routière de
chi minh ville
ce n'est pas lui si vous devez prendre
votre bus la barre au combien de
personnes deux personnes allez-vous de
allez vous asseoir là-bas dans le fond
shao lui etienne partent pour le village
de la jeune fille au coeur du delta du
mékong
le cultivateur chinois va faire la
connaissance de sa future belle famille
mais avant de partir nous l'interrogeons
sur un détail comment vous communiquer
j'ai acheté de livres
montre moi celui ci est pour les
vietnamiens qui apprennent le chinois
celui là et pour les chinois qui
souhaitent apprendre le vietnamien
ça nous suffira dans mon village les
vietnamiennes parle chinois au bout de
trois mois tant qu'on ne parle pas la
même langue on n'a pas grand chose à se
dire
dix heures de trajet sans échangé le
moindre mot le voyage est interminable
petit à petit chat ou lui prend ses
aises et tu viennes par est embarrassé
à présent ils vont traverser le mékong
en ferry l'occasion pour chats au lieu
de s'isoler et de méditer sur le sens de
son voyage
je vois rarement des paysages comme
celui ci je n'ai pas eu beaucoup
d'occasions de prendre le bateau dans ma
vie
et ça vaut le coup d'aller aussi loin
pour épouser une femme oui je suis prêt
à tout pour parvenir à mes fins
en fin de journée
charles hué tuyen arrive au village de
la jeune fille en bordure du mékong
les habitants vivent du maraîchage et de
la culture du riz une vie plus que
modeste
tuyen est sa famille habite dans une
maison en tôle sans fenêtre et sans
électricité
ciao lui va être surpris par la froideur
de l'accueil personne ne le salut
étienne parent aussitôt vaquer à ses
occupations
le cultivateur chinois est complètement
perdue
c'est le papa c'est le papa de sienne
l'homme est en fait le cld de la jeune
fille mais personne n'a pris la peine de
l'expliquer h à aulus la méfiance des
vietnamiens à son égard et manifestent
pour briser la glace
il valait faire rêver en chine tuyen
pourra trier le t elle gagnera 20 euros
par jour par jour par mois par jour
c'est vraiment beaucoup
si elle veut bien travailler à le
gagnera bien sa vie on est vraiment
riche là bas et pour le prouver
charles lui donne sur le champ 80 euros
à la famille pour qu'elle organise la
cérémonie de mariage dernier à tapis sur
femme à la vue des billets l'atmosphère
se détend par magie
cela fait déjà trois semaines que
charles huet au vietnam il aimerait
retourner rapidement en chine avec sa
conquête
il va mettre la pression sur la famille
pour fixer le plus vite possible
la date du mariage
dans sept jours alors ok pour sept jours
une semaine ça va mais pas plus je reste
plus je perds de l'argent
j'ai déjà dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour
votre fille comment la famille de tuyen
at-elle été contacté par les trafiquants
comment ce réseau illégal est il
organisé retour à hô chi minh ville
ce soir nous avons rendez vous avec des
personnages clés de ce trafic de femmes
c'est la première fois qu'il parle pas
des journalistes
nous les avons convaincus de témoigner à
visage découvert
autour de la table quatre personnes
l'homme en bleu et la jeune femme en
robe léopard sont des vietnamiens ce
sont eux qui on repère et huillet ils
l'ont mis en contact avec madame wang la
trafiquante chinoise qui elle refuse
toujours d'être filmé le jeune homme en
tee shirt blanc est également chinois
c'est lui qui est chargé de recruter les
acheteurs de femmes il s'appelle mots
nous aurons l'occasion de le revoir
ce soir les trafiquants consultent des
photos de jeunes vietnamiennes une sorte
de catalogue pour les branchés sol est
actuellement à hô chi minh ville
elles sont toutes paysanne si elle
accepte d'aller en chine c'est parce
qu'avec le développement économique
les chinois sont plus riches qu'avant et
les familles voulaient payer combien je
ne peux pas te dire je ne peux pas te
dire
nous apprendrons plus tard qu'en moyenne
les trafiquants verse 300 euros à chaque
famille c'est tout un réseau mais il y a
beaucoup de travail derrière on a des
relais partout en chine comme au vietnam
tout seul et comment vous faites pour
donner des papiers officiels aux femmes
on a deux très bonnes relations ici
et pour l'argent vous faites comment y
donnera c'est une affaire comme les
autres on se partage les bénéfices et
ses trafiquants font d'autant plus de
bénéfices qu'ils proposent des femmes
vierges les branches esseulé les
achètent plus cher
retour à l'hôtel en caméra cachée nous
retrouvons des chinois qui à linverse de
xiaolu n'ont toujours pas rencontré de
vietnamienne nous allons voir qu'ils ont
une théorie très curieuse sur la
virginité
toi tu as trouvé une femme vierge non
c'est difficile d'en trouver les
vitamines et non leur première relation
sexuelle dès l'âge de 15 ans parfois
même plus tôt à 13 ou 14 ans tout ça
c'est à cause de la chaleur
c'est quoi le rapport avec la chaleur
quand il fait chaud les seins des femmes
poussent plus vite
donc elles commencent leur vie sexuelle
plus tôt nous retrouvons chez lui dans
un quartier de chi minh ville près de
l'hôtel où il loge il à tromper la
surveillance des trafiquants pour aller
s'acheter une chemise en vue du mariage
avec lui trois autres branches est seul
et originaires de sa région en chine
c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils viennent à
hô chi minh ville nous allons comprendre
pourquoi
celle-là a l'air pas mal
je vais essayer pour voir ça te va c'est
bien pour toi la taille aussi ça doit
aussi si shao lui regrette d'avoir
acheté cette chemise
il pourra revenir l'échanger contre une
autre il en va de même pour les femmes
vietnamiennes
c'est précisément la raison pour
laquelle les compagnons de shao lui sont
de retour à hô chi minh ville
ils sont venus rendre leur faim la fille
que j'ai achetés ne veut pas rester chez
moi en chine
je reviens pour l'échangé
défi échangeables moyennant un
supplément de 1000 euros les acheteurs
ont un mois pour en faire la demande
c'est en quelque sorte le service après
vente que proposent les trafiquants vous
n'êtes pas triste de revenir ici
non c'est juste pour un échange
non je la connais à peine j'ai pas de
sentiment
[Musique]
sept jours plus tard à quelques heures
de la cérémonie du mariage
les parents de tuyen ont à nouveau le
sourire ils viennent de recevoir des
cadeaux et de l'argent
nous réalisons que shao lui a encore
quelques lacunes
[Musique]
chalus elle s'appelle comment ta femme
fan machine
c'est une machine ça veut dire quoi
c'est la traduction de son nom en
chinois et son vrai nom vietnamien
voilà je ne sais pas
la vaisselle est empruntée aux habitants
du village la famille de thuyone a prévu
un repas exceptionnel des fruits de mer
un mets très rare
[Musique]
tuyen a dépensé 10 euros une somme non
négligeable pour louer trois robes
différentes
la fête est organisée au milieu de la
route sous un chapiteau la famille
vietnamienne est fier de montrer à tout
le village que leur fille est parvenue a
épousé un riche chinois pour
immortaliser l'événement
séance photo même à cette occasion du
yen continue de repousser les élans de
chats onu pas même un baiser sur le
front
[Musique]
mais brusquement l'ambiance bascule
tuyen se démaquille elle a troqué ses
robes contre un pyjama rayé bye bye
son père est furieux dégage shao lui ne
comprend pas la situation
il est perplexe
il faut demander à l'intermédiaire de
venir si elle ne vient pas je te laisse
pas partir
l'intermédiaire
c'est madame wang la trafiquante qui a
vendu des yens h à aulus si le père veut
la voir en urgence c'est qu'il vient de
réaliser que le mariage n'a aucune
valeur légale
quand tu viennes ira en chine rien ne
prouvera qu'elle est bien la femme de
shao lui
la tension monte l'oncle de tuyen ici
derrière la table connaît bien
l'administration
c'est un agent de l'état il prend les
choses en main il appelle madame wang
nous filmons discrètement la
conversation il veut se marier mais il
n'y a pas de papiers
je vous répète qu'il nous faut le
certificat de mariage signé et délivré
par le département de la justice
c'est ma nièce je connais la procédure
je ne laisserai pas partir
j'ai déjà payé pour ses papiers et
beaucoup d'argent en plus
ils conviennent d'un rendez vous avec la
trafiquante et celle ci va trouver une
astuce pour débloquer la situation
elles arrivent avec un visa chinois d'un
mois au nom de tuyen ce n'est pas le
document que la famille attendait il ne
lui donne aucune garantie mais il va
contribuer à calmer les esprits
tu vois il ya un tampon du ministère et
celui de l'ambassade de chine au vietnam
le lendemain matin à quelques minutes du
départ
charles hué tuyen n'ont pas dormi
ensemble madame wang la trafiquante
interdit aux couples d'avoir des
relations sexuelles avant l'arrivée en
chine
c'est la règle si l'homme chinois veut
échanger sa femme dans les jours qui
suivent la rencontre
celle ci doit être encore vierge pour ne
pas perdre sa valeur
une dernière prière pour le voyage et
c'est l'heure de la séparation
[Musique]
comment vous envisagez votre vie future
une vie simple tu pense qu'elle va aimer
la chine
je n'en sais rien
je pense que vous serez amoureux un jour
je ne sais vraiment pas et c'est parti
pour sept jours de trajet pendant
lesquels ils prendront l'avion le bus et
la voiture nous les retrouverons dans
une semaine dans le village de shiao lui
en attendant nous faisons une halte sur
la route à la frontière côté chinois
[Musique]
ce site aux paysages idylliques
s'appelle détiennent il attire de
nombreux touristes
kim 30 ans est l'une des guides qui des
promenades à cheval est la vietnamienne
elle aussi a été acheté par un chinois
c'était il ya dix ans quelle vie mènent
tel aujourd'hui est elle satisfaite de
sa condition
[Musique]
nous la retrouvons chez elle une maison
en parpaings à flanc de montagne
elle vit au milieu de ces animaux avec
sa fille et son mari monsieur lee ici à
gauche sur l'image
ils ne travaillent pas et se laisse
entretenir par kim qui gagnent 200 euros
par mois son salaire nourrit toute la
famille
[Musique]
kim ne se plaint pas de sa situation
matérielle quant à la vie de couple à ce
que ton mari et m je pense que oui sinon
pourquoi se marier il est gentil avec
toi oui c'est à dire disons que s'il ne
m'insulte pas c'est un miracle s'il ne
m'insulte pas s'il ne me bats pas c'est
un miracle
pourquoi tu pleures question qui me rend
trop triste comment ils traitent ils
m'insultent je suis très triste
à l'instar des kim
les vietnamiennes en chine sont souvent
vulnérables elles n'ont pas de papiers
ne peuvent accéder par exemple à la
propriété et sont à la merci des humeurs
de leurs maris xiaolu étui yens roule
désormais dans les montagnes du sud-est
de la chine
regarde il ya une fitna mienne qui
habite là-bas
tuyen découvre son nouveau village thing
chat qui comme celui de ses parents est
construit le long d'un cours d'eau à
présent c'est l'instant de vérité la
mère de shao lui accueille
chaleureusement sa nouvelle belle fille
mais celle ci se montre embarrassé
presque apeurée elle s'accroche au bras
de sa belle mère elle l'a conduit devant
ce qui sera désormais sa maison et sa
chambre contre c'est ta chambre
on va manger d'abord rentrer vas-y comme
la famille de la mariée au vietnam
quelques jours plus tôt la famille de
shao lui va cuisiner des plats de fête
mais tuyen est toujours mal à l'aise
[Musique]
tout le village ou presque est convié à
ce repas de bienvenue
autour de la table beaucoup de personnes
âgées et d'anciennes branche esseulé qui
se sont mariés à des vietnamiennes pour
tuyen ces femmes seront des points de
repère
malgré l'ambiance chaleureuse la jeune
fille ne se déride pas et charles huet
inquiets ils aimeraient que leur union
soit consommée dans la nuit il cherche à
amadouer sa femme
mon père est mort de la maladie de
parkinson
ma mère nourrit toute seule la famille
elle emprunte partout de l'argent pour
qu'on puisse survivre
son rêve est d'avoir un petit enfant de
son vivant isolation avoir développé la
théorie la taille s'il te plaît sois
gentil avec moi
sinon ma mère va devenir folle mais
tuyen est insensible aux supplications
de son nouveau mari elle décide
d'appeler sa mère pour lui raconter ses
premières impressions
comme elle parle vietnamien personne ne
la comprend
je te téléphone pour que tu sache ce
n'est pas du tout ce qui nous avait dit
c'est la campagne et après de commerce
comme il nous avait dit c'est juste une
maison en bois
je m'inquiète beaucoup
non y'a rien du tout là on est dans les
montagnes les montagnes je te rapelle
demain on est en train de manger je dois
te laisser jouer à clessé tuyen
peut-elle décidé de rentrer chez elle et
abandonner son mari c'est la grande
angoisse de xiaolu et dont l'histoire du
trafic
le cas est fréquent même après le
mariage et l'arrivée en chine
nous allons le constater à nanning une
ville chinoise de 7 millions d'habitants
près de la frontière vietnamienne
nous retrouvons mots l'un des
trafiquants que nous avions filmé lors
de la réunion chi minh ville
ce soir il a rendez-vous avec l'un de
ses hommes de main dans un appartement
d'une résidence populaire il doit régler
un problème en urgence
combien de jours qu'elle est là ça fait
10 jours qu'elle est là white ou
vietnamienne de 21 ans vient d'être
vendu 1 cuisine et chinois mais elle
éprouve de la répulsion physique pour
son époux et la chine la déçoit du coup
elle veut rentrer au vietnam et des
parents ils ont dit quoi au départ ma
mère m'a dit de faire des efforts parce
que nous sommes déjà marié je lui ai dit
que je ne voulais pas couché avec lui je
veux rentrer finalement ma mère est
d'accord avec moi comme sa mère son mari
cuisinier a donné son accord pour
qu'elle rentre au pays
il sera remboursé en parti mauve a
raccompagné en personne white ou pour
qu'elle retourne dans sa famille une
protection rapprochée
rien n'échappe au contrôle des
trafiquants
deux jours plus tard à hô chi minh ville
un rendez vous est fixé pour les
retrouvailles sur un parking
white ou semble inquiète comme si elle
craignait que personne ne vienne la
chercher et finalement son téléphone
sonne vous êtes tous vous êtes à côté du
centre commercial
[Musique]
étrange scène où la famille qui l'a
vendue semble émue de la revoir quelques
jours plus tard au village de tim chat
en chine
cela fait quelques jours que le couple a
emménagé et le mariage n'a toujours pas
été consommé
puis yen ne cesse de repousser ce moment
comme si au delà du sexe elle refusait
de s'engager dans cette nouvelle vie
dans un nouveau pays les autres
vietnamienne du village lui propose de
se joindre à elle elles vont jouer aux
cartes dans la maison d'un chinois
tuyen hésite puis les suit mais son
nouveau mari ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille
il va faire preuve d'autorité et vient
reprendre sa femme non on n'y va pas je
t'interdis d'y aller
rentrer avec moi si je lui interdis
c'est que j'ai mes raisons
je t'assure si je lui ai interdit d'y
aller c'est que j'ai mes raisons
un très jeune couple qui ne parvient pas
à communiquer
difficile de savoir si le mariage va
résister à l'épreuve du temps
le cultivateur est heureux de ne plus
être une branche esseulé mais que
décidera t-il si son épouse continue de
le repousser
quand as-tu yens elle a compris qu'elle
ne serait jamais riche il n'est pas
exclu qu'elle cherche elle aussi à
s'enfuir mais dans ses campagnes très
reculées les montagnes seront peut-être
ces barrières
on
en